well earlier the Russian President
Vladimir Putin called the blast on the
bridge connecting Crimea to Mainland
Russia a terrorist act the Russian
president blamed Ukraine's special
services and he's set to hold a meeting
of Russia's Security Council later on
Monday the courage Bridge supplies
moscow's troops in southern Ukraine and
is seen as a symbol of Russian power in
the region Ukraine has not claimed
responsibility
there is no doubt this is an act of
terrorism aimed at destroying Russia's
critical civilian infrastructure its
authors perpetrators and beneficiaries
are the security services of Ukraine
let's bring in Muhammad while he's
joining us from Moscow so Muhammad
certainly the view in Ukraine amongst
them is that these attacks that have
just taken place in the past couple of
hours are in retaliation for the Crimea
Bridge attack what are you hearing from
the Kremlin
yes Darin the deputy chairman of the
National Security Council Dmitry
Medvedev made a statement today on his
account on telegram saying that the same
the same words that use put in use that
this is a terrorist attack on Russia and
that the terrorists should be killed all
of them should be killed and he said
this is what the Russians are expecting
and we have heard these statements even
before the results of the investigation
came out yesterday many times from Party
leaders from Parliament members and so
on all of them talking about Ukraine
pointing the finger of accusation at
Ukraine and saying that if proved
Ukraine should be punished and Russia
should strike hard at the targets and
not only any Targets but vital
infrastructure across the country and
that's what we are seeing today in a way
uh also this meeting today by President
Vladimir Putin with the National
Security Council
comes when there is uh you know there is
increasing talk about increasing use of
the word terrorism and rumors and
reports in the media that probably there
might be a change to the nature of the
operation the new name might be and this
is just expectations so far might be
anti an anti-terrorism operation the the
word terrorism is now the most
frequently used word here in Russia and
we are expecting president Vladimir's
putting to speak after the meeting today
and everyone is waiting for what he's
going to say all right you'll keep us
across that story for the time being
Muhammad thank you for that update from
Moscow let's speak to Alexandra who's a
security and defense policy analyst and
the editor-in-chief of the Swiss
military review he's in Geneva that's
where he's joining us from welcome to Al
Jazeera so several locations as I'm sure
you're aware have been targeted in
Ukraine including the capital which
hasn't been hit for for some months now
just give me your initial thoughts on
these developments
when Ukraine most probably struck at
this bridge they have in fact extended
the battlefield to the the rear echelons
to the supply infrastructure of the
Russian forces that are fighting right
now in Ukraine so the response by the
Russian military forces is to also
extend the battlefield and the the
waging of of strikes to the Ukrainian
capital and the message is quite clear
um the the the the fighting will resume
in areas that are not only directed
directly connected to the fighting but
also into the rear areas where the
population lives where perhaps uh
training is being undertaken with
conscripts for the Ukrainian military so
you think in your mind that this is in
fact directly related then to the Crimea
Bridge attack
this is a direct
um this is a direct correlation and Link
because the ukrainians have been
targeting a number of bridges on the
niepra river and they have essentially
managed to
make it extremely difficult for the 15
000 Russian forces that are fighting in
the Carson area to receive all of the
replenishments the ammunition the fuel
coming from the rear there are three uh
train uh axes that allow for the
logistical supply of these horses and
one of them is the one that was struck
yesterday how much of this perhaps has
to do with the new Commander for uh the
Air Force General in Russia who's now in
charge I mean does he need to show some
strength now that he's been put in this
position
well if you look at his uh curriculum
you will see that he's not an Air Force
person he was put in charge of the
Russian Air Forces but originally he was
a member of the special forces and
eventually then commanded many different
uh units he has a very uh I will say uh
difficult and challenging uh military
career and and pass he was almost uh
kicked out of the military and on a
number of occasions and definitely he is
perceived as one of the hardliners but
let's be clear he does not control the
operation it is the Russian president
who is the main boss and who decides
what gets targeted and when so the
Ukrainian defense Ministry has now come
out and said that they are vowing
revenge for Monday strikes on the
country is this going to
um shift the war
um is this going to perhaps see a
significant escalation in the war
it is an escalation and as I said by
targeting Kiev it is now possible to
send this deliberate message even the
Border towns next to the Polish border
can be targeted where you see all of the
NATO weapons are coming in and the
troops are being trained so this is
definitely an extension of the conflict
the answer to your question is this
going to be effective yes or no it will
depend very much on the mentality on the
opinion in Ukraine I don't think that
this is going to change the point of
view of most of the Ukrainian people
it's going to put them definitely under
pressure and so far they have resisted
quite well under pressure and what about
the International Community does this
change anything for for the West
well of course when you are targeting uh
the capital city and you don't really
know what you're firing at and civilians
are dying and a lot of this ammunition
is blowing up right next to the largest
nuclear power plant in Europe uh this is
not a good sign it's not a good message
and I think
um you know perhaps over the past few
weeks there have been hesitations among
European leaders I don't see any
European leader coming out today and say
we need to negotiate and you know let's
also examine uh Russia's point of view
and they may be legitimate in their
claims I think this is going to probably
consolidate the European position okay
we'll leave it there we thank you so
much for speaking to us from Geneva